>> Sean: REACTION TO THE
WRECKING NEWS TONIGHT.
WHY WE FIGHT, JUST OUT THIS
WEEK, DEFEATING AMERICA'S
ENEMIES WITH NO APOLOGIES.
FOX NEWS NATIONAL SECURITY
STRATEGIST SEBASTIAN GORKA, OUT,
COMPETING FOR THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" TOP SPOT WITH TUCKER
CARLSON, THE AUTHOR OF "SPYGATE"
FORMER SECRET SERVICE AGENT, TC
CONTRIBUTOR, DAN BONGINO, PAM
BONDY, HERSELF A VICTOR OF THE
MOB.
FAKE NEWS CNN SAYS YOU CAN'T USE
THE TERM ROB.
YOU, SECRETARY NIELSEN, SARAH
SANDERS, TED CRUZ.
THIS IS A MOB THAT IS BEING
INCITED BY PEOPLE LIKE MAXINE
WATERS.
FOLLOW THEM INTO DEPARTMENT
STORES AND RESTAURANTS.
IF ANY CONSERVATIVE DID TO A
DEMOCRATIC WOMAN WHO WAS DONE TO
YOU, PAM, THERE WOULD BE FIRE
AND FURY TO USE A PHRASE.
>> THERE CERTAINLY WOULD, SEAN.
AND IT'S THE CLASSIC DEFINITION
OF A MOB.
IF YOU LOOK UP WHAT A MONIES IN
THE DICTIONARY, IT'S INCITING
VIOLENCE.
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
I WAS BOOED AGAIN THE OTHER
NIGHT, SOMEONE SAW ME, AND
YELLED MY NAME LIKE THEY HAD WON
THE LOTTERY, THE LOTTERY OF
GETTING TO BE MEAN TO A HUMAN
BEING.
YOU KNOW THAT'S WHAT THE WORLD
IS TURNING INTO.
>> Sean: BUT THEY'RE DOING IT TO
WOMEN, VT PEOPLE THAT SAY THAT
THEY HAVE A MONOPOLY,
COMPASSION, AND CONSERVATIVES
DON'T.
>> EXACTLY.
>> Sean: I'M SORRY YOU HAD TO GO
THROUGH THAT.
OH, I'M NOT GOING TO BE A
VICTIM.
>> Sean: THIS IS NOW WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING TO DO.
WE'RE SEEING IT DAILY.
AND IT IS A MOB.
DEMOCRATS ARE INCITING THIS WITH
THEIR WORDS IN MANY WAYS.
>> THEY ARE.
BUT I THINK THIS IS HAPPENING
FOR A REASON.
I THINK IN THIS TRUMP ERA WHERE
NOW TRUMP JUST REFUSES TO BACK
DOWN, TO THIS POLITICAL
PRESSURE, THROUGH THE MEDIA, THE
LIBERAL SWAMP, AND THESE
ACTIVIST GROUPS, IT'S ENRAGED
THEM.
SHAWN, THE LEFT, FOR AS MUCH AS
I DISAGREE WITH THEM
IDEALOGICALLY, THEY'RE USUALLY
TACTICALLY SMARTER THAN THIS.
TRUMP HAS THEM MOVING IN
SCATTERED, THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
TO DO ANY MORE, THEY'RE NOT USED
TO A REAL POLITICAL FIGHT.
REPUBLICANS -- ELECTED
REPUBLICANS WOULD HAVE BACKED
DOWN AND TRUMP REFUSES TO DO IT.
>> Sean: LOOKING AT TED CRUZ
WITH HIS WIFE, HE HAS TO ESCORT
HIS WIFE AND ACT AS PROTECTION
TO GET HER OUT OF THE
RESTAURANT, DR. GORE KASHGS THEY
CAN'T LET -- GORECA, THEY CAN'T
LET PEOPLE SIT FOR FIVE MINUTES
IN PEACE.
>> THINK ABOUT THE METRIC, THAT
YOU RISK BODILY HARM IF YOU PUT
ON A RED MAGA HAT IN MANY PARTS
OF THE UNITED STATES.
THAT'S ACTUALLY AN ACT OF
COURAGE.
THE LEFT WALKS AROUND IN
T-SHIRTS, WITH CHE GUEVAR.
A MASS MURDERER ON THEIR CHEST.
WE DON'T DO ANYTHING TO THEM.
THE MID TERMS ARE CRUCIAL.
DO YOU WANT THE MOB TO RUN
AMERICA?
DO YOU WANT PEOPLE WHO WILL
INTIMIDATE YOU IF YOU DO NOT TOE
THEIR LINE?
THAT'S WHAT THE NEXT 26 DAYS ARE
WITH.
ARE ABOUT.
>> Sean: PAM, WHEN KANYE SAID
TODAY THAT IT'S FREEING, REALLY
IT IS A SIGN OF COURAGE, I'M NOT
GOING TO -- I'M NOT GOING TO LET
ANYBODY TELL ME HOW TO THINK AND
WEAR MY "MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN" HAT, HE COULD HAVE PULLED
BACK ON THE CURSING IN THE OVAL
OFFICE, BUT WE'LL PUT IT ASIDE.
MOST PEOPLE HAVE CURSED IN THEIR
LIVES.
BUT IT'S SAD THAT WE HAVE THE
BEST, THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT,
FOR AFRICAN-AMERICANS, HISPANIC
AMERICANS, ASIAN-AMERICANS.
AND SOMEBODY SAY GOOD JOB.
LET DOZEN MORE OF THIS.
>> AND KANYE IS A BUSINESSMAN,
SEAN.
HE'S A CAPITAL INTEREST.
AND HE UNDERSTANDS THAT.
HE'S SAYING LET'S MAKE MORE
PRODUCTS IN THE UNITED STATES.
HE GETS IT.
HE KNOWS ALL OF THE GOOD THAT
THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE FOR THE
COUNTRY.
AND KANYE WEST IS BRAVE.
HE'S HIS OWN MAN, NOT SCARED TO
SPEAK HIS MIND AND WEAR HIS MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN HAT.
NONE OF US ARE GOING TO BE
VICTIMS.
TED CRUZ WAS OUT THERE
PROTECTING HIS WIFE.
EVERYONE IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO
DO WHAT'S RIGHT.
DESPITE WHAT THE FORMER CHIEF
LEGAL OFFICER OF OUR ENTIRE
COUNTRY SAID TO KICK PEEP WHEN
THEY'RE DOWN.
IT'S DESPICABLE.
I KNOW ERIC HOLDER, HE SHOULD BE
ASHAMED.
>> Sean: I'M SURE I DON'T AGREE
ON EVERYTHING WITH KANYE WEST, I
DISAGREE ON STOP AND FRISK, IT
WORKED.
BUT I AGREE ON SAFER CITIES, I
AGREE ON PRISON REFORM, MAKE
PRODUCTS IN AMERICA AND CREATE
JOBS FOR AMERICANS.
I'M ALL IN.
>> SEAN, I HAVE BEEN VOCAL ABOUT
THIS.
I WISH A LOT OF ESTABLISHMENT
TYPE REPUBLICANS WHO ARE SELLING
THIS MOMENT SHORT WOULD TAKE A
TIME-OUT AND THINK ABOUT THIS.
WHERE HAVE WE FELL SHORT OVER
THE YEARS.
CULTURAL CAPITAL.
DEMOCRATS BUILT UP A BANK
ACCOUNT OF CULTURAL CAPITAL
THROUGH HOLLYWOOD, AND WE HAVE
PEOPLE SAYING HEY, THESE
REPUBLICANS AREN'T CRAZY, SEE
WHAT THEY HAVE TO SAY.
IT'S A BIG DEAL.
>> Sean: DR. GORKA, YOU CLEANED
UP REALLY WELL.
[LAUGHING]
WE'LL GIVE YOU THE LAST WORD.
>> LOOK, IT'S VERY, VERY SIMPLE.
THEY HAVE NO POLICIES, THEY HAVE
NO ARGUMENT, ALL THEY HAVE IS
INTIMIDATION.
AND WE WILL NOT LET THEM GET
AWAY WITH IT.